one of the things that is going to be
required if indeed Donald Trump wants to
cut the payroll tax to zero through the
end of the year is he's going to have to
meet with Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi is
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives Democrats control the
House of Representatives Trump is a
Republican
Trump's going to need to meet with Nancy
Pelosi and Donald Trump is refusing to
meet with Nancy Pelosi about all of the
different things he's considering doing
including cutting that payroll tax to
deal with the virus that's basically the
whole story
Donald Trump met with Senate Republicans
about a response but Democrats control
the house you need Democrats in order to
pass things Trump proposed the payroll
tax cut through the end of the year but
you've got to talk to House Democrats
they control the house you're not going
to be able to do it without them and
Donald Trump is reportedly refusing to
meet with Nancy Pelosi apparently for no
other reason that he just wouldn't be
able to bear being in the same room as
her here's even jabbers explaining what
it is that's going on Pelosi
it doesn't look like it would be
productive at this point to put Donald
Trump and Nancy Pelosi in the same room
together negotiating face to face it
just doesn't seem like that would end
well so minuchin support that because
he's so wounded and we were in the
middle of a national crisis and he can't
get in a room with the Speaker of the
House look I mean what the White House
would say is that's Pelosi's fault right
because she ripped up his speech she's
been tough on him she impeached him and
therefore the president has every right
to not want to be in a room with her but
look I mean that's where we are in
American politics today right I mean you
the idea that we could have face-to-face
negotiations between the Speaker of the
House and the president of United States
is just far-fetched right now even in
this crisis Trump was actually invited
by Nancy Pelosi to the st. Patrick's Day
lunch which is it's a bipartisan event
that days back dates back to 1983 and
Trump declined the invitation is it
possible Nancy Pelosi might be able to I
don't know attempt Trump to show up if
she promises to get him one of those big
taco salad from Trump Tower that Trump
likes so much or maybe a bucket of KFC
which Donald Trump also has a penchant
for I don't know what it's going to take
but this is not leaders
this is childish it's endangering the
country it is increasing the number of
people who are at risk Trump needs Nancy
Pelosi and needs House Democrats in
order to get things done on this
pandemic and that is what it now is
according to the w-h-o Trump is refusing
to meet with Nancy Pelosi he just won't
meet with her
Trump addressing the nation last night
on this issue of the virus demanding all
sorts of people do different things and
yet he can't get himself into a room
with Nancy Pelosi to actually figure
things out like adults and maybe cut
payroll taxes through the end of the
year this is the height or the bottom
the the barrel bottom of the barrel of
total childish nonsense from the White
House while everyone else is expected to
kowtow to him and to follow his lead but
his lead is a ridiculous joke and the
guy is refusing to meet with Nancy
Pelosi III I don't ever want to be on
this program what's the word
inaccurately pessimistic overly
pessimistic but when I see the data and
I see the numbers and then I see Trump's
address to the nation last night just
riddled with lies things that just
aren't true insurance companies are
waiving co-pays on treatments no they're
not that's just not true they're not
they immediately put out a statement
saying that they're not I am starting to
genuinely worried that what we are
talking about here is a potentially you
know year or longer Fiasco and by that I
mean that we might get the virus under
control in under a year but in terms of
the economic repercussions we could be
talking about a year plus or multi-year
Fiasco if an adult can't get this under
control soon and that's why later in the
program I am going to argue that it is
Donald time for Donald Trump to resign
let's take a quick break make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show we'll
continue to cover this there and while
you are on Instagram follow me at David
Pakman I want to give a quick shout out
to one of our sponsors VIN Charo watches
they're giving my audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch maybe you don't
usually wear a watch and you've been
thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out VIN Charo it's an American
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even Cheryl watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really love the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
loved this one they also sent me the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family
anytime you see me wearing a watch on
the show I'm wearing a Ventura watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch